nein nein
fast alle mit freude und willkommen zur
capt f2p irgendwas mit go strafe sind
schon bald zwanzig mittlerweile ja sind
wir hier haben was jetzt gerade schön
erstmal eine kokosnuss gewachsen
wundervoll wir haben ja schon relativ
viele monumente geschafft in der letzten
folge haben wir das hier geschafft nicht
einen moment sondern das war gold blöcke
darauf aber die haben sich irgendwie zu
steinblöcken verwandelt weil die nicht
wollen dass man das irgendwie doppelt
benutzt diese gold blöcke ist auch
eigentlich an sinnvoll wir haben den
doppel aber eh schon geschafft und wir
müssen jetzt irgendwie mal versuchen
hier noch ein paar andere monumente
hinzukriegen
da gibt es noch pink magenta ich noch
heute dem emerald weil ich denke mal
wenn wir beide jetzt in die höhe gehen
und wie wie die bekloppten irgendwie was
wir im reifen noch sammeln wir brauchen
also ich habe
wir haben schon einen blog auf emerald
und noch sechs emerald so viel
unterbrochen wir brauchen drei wir
brauchen noch zwölf emirates insgesamt
die befinden ist nicht so wichtig die
eine hat doch so viele davon warte mal
bekomme ich hoch und bringen die mal
eben vor bei 45 minuten ich habe aber
schon viele von abgebaut haben ach so na
ja trotzdem sind ich mache mir einfach
eine spitzhacke und das band einfach wie
ein körper von meiner nase soll ich
schon mal die haben an schwert machen
gerne im moment als es eng wurde kiebers
bonner weil wir brauchen eine diamant
spitzhacke um auch ein diamant schnitt
um nachher dass mit diesem acht herzen
schaden zu schaffen so ich habe einen
diamant schwert gemacht jetzt mache ich
mir noch eben zwei spitzhacken und mir
noch eine leuchtrakete wird immer
irgendwas im schatten steht uhr immer
wenn irgendwas in szeged denke ich mir
so [ __ ] aber egal wir wollen in dieser
folge auf jeden fall dass
moment mit dem erwirtschaften und wir
hoffen immer noch darauf dass ein
schwein irgendwann bei rauskommt oh ja
das wäre ein traum
ich las die das ja manchmal da einfach
in der werkstatt daran ja mach das mal
ich bin hier gerade so ein wenig in
einer angespannten situation weil ich
fast wieder mal tot bin war ja auch was
hier ist ein konkretes bonner der ich
bin tot war grad sagen ich werde von tag
da ist irgendwann creepers borner de ich
weiß nicht in welcher wand versteckt
aber dass bonn immer wieder neue krippe
bist du ganz unten gewesen in dieser
links neben dieser zwischen höhle wo wir
damals so viel gold und so hat und wo
auch die rose drinstand wer weiß welche
ich meine jetzt aber okay das sind
richtig viele monster
ich schaue mal ganz gut sagt habe hier
in lava see gefunden muss jetzt auch
recht vorsichtig sein
ja ich hole ich bin wirklich nur auf der
suche nach mr als grad ich möchte keiner
will wo ich gerade war wie gesagt da
sind noch einige sind bestimmt
mindestens acht stück die man einfach so
abhauen kann aber das sind halt viele
monster und deswegen ist das relativ
schwierig deswegen ja entweder wir
finden die sportler brauchen die ab und
ich hab auch keine fackeln also wir
müssen da ich habe elf fackeln ich bin
noch grad hinter dir ich war eben in der
höhle noch ein bisschen als abbauen blog
gibts gar nicht dass ein bisschen
traurig weil davon die richtig richtig
viel und block auf diamant wird auch
noch richtig schwer weil wir haben noch
fünf diamanten oben und man braucht pro
block 9 stück das er als drei mal neun
sind 27 dafür fünf haben noch 22
diamanten
wir brauchen noch 22 diamanten und zwölf
emerald
ich bin bei dir tonnen liegen irgendwo
meine sachen oder auseinander men und da
unten ist eine richtig dicke immer welt
quelle glaube ich wenn ich das gerade
richtig gesehen habe sind auch richtig
viele mops passau findet ihr die
sbornaja jetzt bei dir und du bist auch
gleich gut
ich sehe es schon kommen okay er jeden
moment jeden moment man kann ja nicht
einfach untergehen man kann ja nicht
einfach untergehen
und ich hab keine spitzhacke womit ich
dir helfen kann ich mir auch gleich tot
bin mein gott mein volk angekurbelt
hatte nein nein was machen wir jetzt
fühle wie botnets schnellen ausreise wer
mehr eisen übrig und bei den eisen
schwert und probieren vielleicht müssten
wenn sie vielleicht doch nicht die macht
den schweren unfall am tisch mit martin
schwerdt ich hab genug eisen für ok
super alter wie war das denn machen soll
ja nur ein sturz und blöcke mitnehmen
und fackeln kann man nicht irgendwie ich
hatte kati super idee menschen darunter
damit die ganzen absterben und natürlich
auch unser ganz sexy macht auch
alteigner ich nehme ich so kann man
vielleicht gezielte einsetzen
da kann man bestimmte sachen mitspringen
ich nehme noch ein paar steine mit so
und wir schaffen das jetzt kommen
einfach jetzt anders machen dies die sbo
haus sonst also ich gebe meine sachen
noch zwei minuten
nächstes mal wie wie lange ich glaube
fünf minuten geht dass er genau getrennt
ich bin ja auch schon vor fünf minuten
in etwa gestorben oder ich würde sagen
der aufnahme sofort wird drei minuten
ja okay dann passt es mit zwei minuten
hinter super war ich habe echt angst mir
vielleicht noch den rücken gestärkt aber
ich hab nur die spitze ganz schwert und
fackeln
ich hab 27 blöcke wir müssen ja echt gut
vorgehen weil ich weiss noch mit meiner
folge da bin ich eine komplette folge
lang gestorben
nur damit ich meine sachen kommen es ist
viel weiter oben gegangen oder
oder wollen wir bei dem wasserfall nach
unten das war wahrscheinlich auch doof
wir müssen uns wahrscheinlich echt
einfach langsam runter bauen
deswegen ist die spanne überall immer
die küken den monster spawnen diesen
tempel versteckt dieses bonner konnten
sind schon deine sachen gleich da komme
ich gleich rand ja ja ist nun komplett
absitzen nicht einspringen wenn deine
sachen weil du dann du bist danke gott
dass ich länger als skelett ab lenkte
ein körper ab ich gehe mal lieber hier
runter ich habe immer so eine kleine
wand gemacht dass auf jeden fall von da
keiner kommt ja ich bin vielleicht tot
nein nein ich habe den größten teil
meiner sachen gerade im krieg hat gerade
nein ich hab ich habe deine sachen ich
hab dir bringe ich erst mal hoch kannst
du irgendwie hatte alter [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ich kommt ihr gegenüber aloxi
beim mops ein bisschen länger das auch
schon wieder zwei mops kommen ihrem
charme unverantwortlich einbaut gekommen
hoch eigentlich wenn du den weg findest
alter habe dass sich alles mal
ausgeleuchtet irgendwann wie gesagt das
sind zwar die sie machen überall dort
auf wo licht ist der neue monster und
man kann die praktisch das ist so gut
wie unmöglich solange man die spieler
nicht ab dass die hülle und monster
freilich hat mit dieser relativ viele
sachen gerade geschäft so ein bisschen
was auf jeden fall
ich könnte der selbstmord typ seine sich
im rhein stürzt damit die sache nicht
komplett die spawn aber hauptsache du
kommst du hoch ich bin gleich wieder bei
dir kommt man hier mein name ist da
genau
nein nein nein nein ich hab keine blöcke
mich einzubauen
[ __ ] [ __ ] die weg gibt installiert ich
hab's irgendwie habe ich ihn geworfen
schnellschüsse präsidenten laufen ist
immer schwer ein okay okay okay zu
bekommen nicht einmal ein hast du glück
hast nicht einmal noch nicht ich bin da
alle sachen jetzt holt so hier liegt
noch was hier liegt ein sozial schlag
ich jetzt hilfe gemacht dass ein verlag
wie viele e mails herumliegen regel
ruhig umrüstung für dich ich schmeiße
rüstung so kevin und ich bin tot ich bin
so gut wie tot ich bin tot
macht aber nix ich hatte ja nur mal ein
schwert und
paar sachen die ich da noch rum liegen
hatte du lebst noch naja du lebst noch
um sein leben doch ich habe relativ
viele sachen immer noch wenn du eine
rüstung hass auf jeden fall anziehen
ja ich hab ich hab auch für dich rüstung
mit dauern und drauf man junge da sind
so viele e mails in der höhle ehrlich
ich diese hat es so viele auf dem boden
überall liegen da welche und ori oder
sind viele alter manchmal langsam
vorgehen meiner leben generiert sich
dann wieder vergisst du wirst die
wasserfälle und das war so komisch alte
auf einmal war ich auf diesem wasserfall
drauf ob man fit fällst einfach runter
man okay ich komme ich habe uns jetzt
mal so ein bisschen so wir sind jetzt
wieder ein bisschen sicherer hier ich
hab das jetzt mal ein bisschen zugebaut
hier bin bei dir ich werde gleich sport
hier einfach bei uns wären kripo soll
hier das kriegst jetzt von mir aber
bringt n a
und dass dann kriegst auch hier in bogen
und 14 pfeile jetzt habe ich zwei
schwerter und das auch oder war das
richtig es war richtig ich war schon
wieder wasser alter ich habe angst im
wasser bin zwar erst eine spitzhacke nur
eine verdammt was machen wir jetzt
stabil bleiben das machen wir jetzt
wir müssen ich habe mir einen bogen ich
trete erst mal dass keine krüper spawn
aber dem wehr ausgeleuchtet ich nehme
aber einen bogen und schießt ein
bisschen rum da du penner die skelett
ist erstmal das wichtigste finde ich ja
alter sind da viele creeper man da sind
ja viele
wir brauchen nur des areals ist der
körperscanner kannst du mich vielleicht
ein bisschen beschützen werde ich da
hingehöre panikartig kann man hier von
hinten kommen schon wieder zwei skelette
wir müssen gucken wo der clippers bonner
ist und schauen ob die unten noch einmal
sachen rumliegen er hat ja meine spitzer
konkurrenten liegen die sache ich habe
einen emerald er baut ihr nicht jetzt ab
und doch passt alles
die runtergefallen nein nein komme der
scharfe 2 emmel
jetzt kommen die skelette helfen gerade
macht nix ich habe das gerade fertig bin
ich tot
sie sprechen sich auch selber die körper
ja ich baue mir hier ganz so eine kleine
festung so ein bisschen
ja und ich beschütze ich bin so offensiv
mal wir ja du kannst du kannst einfach
zurück in den kader kommt zu mir eine
festung oder irgendwas catedral de hin
ich bin gut ich bin gleich tot alter
überall mops man überall alter ich
möchte gar doch alles auch nur eine halb
letzten spiel auflaufen locker flockig
ich lebe noch hat mich zugebaut alter
ich hätte eh nur auf zwei herzen
explodiert über meinen körper und ich
hatte nur ein halbes okay ich
regeneriere war wieder bei jungen ist
das spannend aber es liegt noch mal
altem sie hatte nicht haben ich habe ich
hab' ich habe fünf emerald ich habe drei
eises schwer das okay aber ich habe
keine spitzhacken 1 komme ich gar nicht
mehr raus und nö sagt du bist dann hätte
ich dich ich bin mein name dürfte es
eigentlich also ich sag mal wo du in
etwa bist doch dann nahm ich den apa
versuchen da unten ein bisschen aber ich
mache das schon selber mit dem schwert
ich bin mir frei musste ich runter kommt
aber schon ein generelles nein es noch
eins klettert das geld ab wenn ich noch
eine spitzhacke links hätte eine
spezielle thomas herzer obmann wo ist
sie hin
später hatte ich habe noch eine
dann könnten wir doppelt so effektiv
habe hier noch ein paar sachen von dir
echt ja hier liegen überall relativ
viele sachen ich wollte da hab ich auch
gestorben
von vorne kommt bei die intruper ich
töte passt sich andrea habe ich
interessiere mich beschützt ich weiß
emmerich wir brauchen noch viel mehr als
ich dachte nur neun in der luft über uns
sind auch wir brauchen insgesamt
insgesamt insgesamt zwölf brauchen wir
okay und ich hab 84 stück brauche ich
glaub ich hab das meiste ja sogar schon
abgebaut
kate kommt auch noch in der luft welche
ich muss ich muss ich muss ich höre noch
ob sich noch ab ich erwarte ich komm
runter zu sehr wenn ich es endlich
schaffen obwohl es keiner inter milano
gold wo sind amerika da oben ist einer
noch er genau da mussten wir an ich bin
dann hier unten und wenn die
runterfallen ist dann wenn ich die ein
okay okay du hast aber gar keine karten
erwirtschafte wasser und mit dem mops ja
ich probiere spd fordert sich im block
nicht dass mich irgendwer unterschied
ich würde ja so heulen ok den hab ich ja
du hast ihn
ich habe ein okay jetzt brauche ich noch
drei was auch von unten wird okay ich
hab das skelett super-g einer genau den
noch wenn er runter fällt macht nix
wollen einfach ab
dann habe ich auch so ich war noch zwei
emery zwar immer noch doch hier so ein
bisschen rum dass gutes hören das ganze
hier oben jetzt ein bisschen mit wegen
voll so da ist glaube ich auch nicht ich
sie da oben das 10 1 und übersichtlicher
raum hier
da oben ist doch ein skelett aber das
sieht mich nicht und davon ist auch noch
ein coup ich bin mir bei dir zwei
emmerichs brauchen wir noch aber hier
sind keine mehr
wir müssen noch mal etwas für glaube ich
oder noch weiter runter bei der anderen
ölen schon ob da noch was drin ist
ich kann mir gut vorstellen wenn wir die
leistung einfach weiter runter gehen
dass dort in der höhe noch als wenn sich
die cross border noch so ein bisschen
erweitert sehe ich da auch noch wieder
einmal
wie kriegen sie auf jeden fall die frage
ist nur wann ja heute noch wenn wir in
die höhle weiter runter gehen
die folge ist auch eigentlich schon
wieder vorbei aber ich möchte das gar
nicht beenden weil wenn wir dass beide
sich das genau das skelett komm wir den
tod der sechs solms vielleicht wieder
ein bisschen kurz hoch gehen auf ein
etwas sichere position
ja ich bin gerade aber am arsch der welt
war
oder liegen noch sachen ja alles
irgendwie mit er das ding ist ich hab
keine spitzer kirche hat gar nicht
hochkommen soll ich brauche jetzt
einfach warte noch auf gommel habe keine
blöcke ich habe null
ich bin hier bei dir ich wir haben nur
zwei herzen deswegen ich möchte nicht
mehr sterben so gribl hälfte er im kader
bisher übrigens doch eigentlich unser
wasser obwohl ist das wasser nach dem
regen wurden hier hier genau hier könnte
hoch war geschafft aber war okay jetzt
hier die treppe weiter dass auf dem
linken skeletten man kann hier immer
noch unter geschossen werden leicht und
doch hoch hier was ich bruno risk no fun
hallo ja jetzt erst mal ein bisschen
sicherer sowohl beim kann hier auch hoch
am besten kannst du ja ganz okay dann
mache ich auf den weg nach oben schon
mal die das ende hier das war jetzt
partner 20 wenn ihr jetzt auch eine
folge auf und danach bin ich im urlaub
das heißt die nächste folge kommt bei
ghom auf dem kanal wenn euch diese
spannungsgeladene folge gefallen hat
zeigt somit einmalig und dann würde ich
sagen wir sehen uns morgen wieder und
der 1